he's in a weird position but he also has
the advantage of being able to
intimidate
I wonder how many people
um
how much is that a roll of it like being
scared of the other person it was usual
I think I think some of the top guys
would deny it but
you know when you're in the seventh hour
and you're playing Magnus it's a very
different feeling than some of the other
when Magnus is messing around in the
opening it's very different than another
person messing around in the opening
you're just kind of like
expect to for something to be there
we'll see if it translates to poker for
him but I think he got he gets a little
bit maybe less respect in the poker
world in the Chess World he's sort of
alpha he gets a lot of respect I just
talked to Daniel on the ground and he
just gets the only person that doesn't
respect Magnus Carlson
honestly either in chess or poker is
Magnus Carl
that's true but like bangus is hilarious
I mean when he talks about his rating
he's like oh it's pretty good when he
talks about how good he's this Pokemon I
suck but you know I think that
self-critical view that he I think he
honestly believes uh to a degree is is
probably part of the the uh the engine
that fuels them to get better and better
and better and better yeah but what I'm
saying is if you if you're face to face
with Magnus on a chessboard it's not the
same as being in a nine-handed poker
table with him you kind of keep an eye
on him maybe in a he's a mysterious guy
but just different because you're like
this is the man
yeah there's very few people yeah so in
uh in poker they talk about Phil Ivey
that way yeah yeah yeah it's like this
super intimidating I think that's that's
probably harder to intimidate in poker
actually I don't know I don't know
there's something intimidating about
like excellence in a determinist Decay
that's just terrifying like you're [ __ ]
I mean it's like playing stockfish like
you're [ __ ] this thing will suffocate
you
and especially when you do makes moves
that you don't understand
this I to me the most beautiful thing
honestly is the sacrifices
that the um the engines do
just the it's such a [ __ ] you yep like I
could sacrifice pieces and I'll get them
back and I'll get them back more and I
could I don't even I don't even have to
get them back your position is so bad I
give you full material and there's
nothing you can do about it yeah that's
terrifying yeah that's terrifying it's
like and that transfers to AI systems in
general like
Like A system that plays weak
just to to fool you